Tổ chứ khi bước mọi đại thời gian nát頭 sẽ tiền hàng cuộc tập trận dân đe hạt nhân thường nghiênh
Mà tên steadfast noon trong buổi cảnh căng thằng an ninh tại Châu Áu đăng ra tăng
C cuộc tập trận gió ha lần dịch đầu kéo dài 2 tuần với sự tham gia của mời miếm mốt mấy bây bây tư, mời buổi của gia thành viên trong đó có miếng
Anh lực, phần lan và bà lan, miếng trên khai mời bây bây nếm bóng bây nếm hài và tìm tích ep bà mấy lắm
Cùng cấp phần tiền tiếp dầu và giám sát, đức nồng gó mấy bây tóc nè đô vào aerofighter đà mẹ bài cho tần công và hợp tổng
Phần lớn hóa đồng diễn giá ở biển bóc, cách sang a bủ quay nà
Nát頭 khẳng định của tập trận đại đất lên kế hoạt từ lâu không xử dụng của khí thật
Tổng thư kiến nát頭 mắc rút tìm cho biết nơi là hóa đậm cân thiết, nhằm bào đam khả năng dân đe hạt nhân an toàn
Ná tiên cạnh và hiệu quà trong tông của của tập trận là bảo vệ của hạt nhân trên mặt đất
Những tại sản được cói là nhẹ cảm và có giả trị trị lực
Sự kiến dễ ra trong bối cảnh nhiều con cửa quân sự choo đăng tăng cửa khẳng giá
Trước các cuộc sâm nhập mận thiết bị bài không ở lấy trong đó còn nghe ngờ liên qua đến ngà
Nát頭 nhìn mạnh của tập trận không nhằm vào của giả của thế nào
Nhưng giờ phần tiết cho rằng đây là thông biệt dành đẹp mạnh mẽ, giữa lúc choo hoa bối mặt nhiều mối đe dọa anh nình